as all of you of well aware Marvel
Studios can do some pretty amazing
things on screen
and since joining the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as dr. Stephen strange I can
tell you that Marvel family is just as
incredible behind the scenes
we're completely inspired and humbled by
the half the strength and the passion of
you our fans each and every one of them
so I'm very excited to announce today a
new charitable initiative that enables
us to do even more together Marvel
Studios hero acts is a global initiative
focused on bringing help and hope to
kids around the world when they need it
most
we film Doctor Strange in Nepal and
several other countries and everywhere
we went in the world I met Marvel fans
but I also saw kids who are facing
enormous challenges challenges that no
one should ever have to face
with the help of our fans hero acts can
change that how what is easy and I know
for my recent trip to Comicon that like
you're really good at this so here it is
to help us launch hero acts post a photo
of yourself in your favorite Marvel hero
pose just go to Marvel Studios hero acts
calm upload your photo and share across
your social media channels with the
below hashtags for every post from now
until the end of the year Marvel Studios
will donate five dollars to the charity
Save the Children this will help them to
provide much-needed learning materials
to as many as 123 thousand kids in the
fall Haiti in the United States
you can learn more at marvel studios
hero acts calm I can't wait to see your
euro poses just to get us started let me
show you Mike
[Music]